hey guys this is Mel and this is our
last lecture in which I'm going to
review some of the things out of your
book that are going to be on the last
exam so we're gonna kind of skip around
on a few topics that I think might have
been a little bit confusing
all of this pertains a climate change
one way or the other so one of the
topics that they talked about in your
book was this idea of a climate model so
a climate model is really a computer
program a very complicated one in the
way that we think about it is imagine if
we took all of the ocean and broke it up
into little cubes and then we took the
surface of the land and broke it up into
little squares and then we took all of
the atmosphere and you broke those up
into cubes now we know all of the
physics that goes on inside each one of
these cubes in the atmosphere and inside
each one of the cubes in the ocean and
what the process is going on inside each
square over the land
so for each cube in the atmosphere for
example we know all the physics all the
thermodynamics all the fluid dynamics
etc that happens in each box and so what
we do is we make a computer program that
does the math that occurs within each
cube in the atmosphere and also each
cube in the ocean and then calculates
what's happening between the squares on
the continents and the cubes in the
atmosphere so it's doing exchange
calculation so here's an example I would
not expect you to know what any of this
math means that each cube of the
atmosphere we can solve all these
different things for each each single
cube now if we did this by hand if we
had enough time we could calculate all
the conditions and all the physics that
are going on inside one cube but we're
trying to
do this for the whole atmosphere so what
we do is we break the atmosphere up into
a bazillion little cubes and then we
have a really really fast computer
generally one that has many processors
and we assign one processor to each cube
so in other words it's like each cube
gets its own little computer that's part
of this big supercomputer so let's skip
that one here the biggest computers the
fastest computers in the world look
something like this and this this one
for a while was the fastest computer in
the world it's has not been that for for
some time now it was called the earth
simulator and all it did was run what we
call climate model so you program in all
of those equations for all those boxes
in the atmosphere and the ocean in the
land and then you essentially you know a
computer like this might have a couple
hundred thousand processors and you sign
a processor to each box and they're all
solving these equations simultaneously
so it takes a lot of computer power to
do this and so early computer models
back then they actually started this in
the 70s when computers were pretty slow
and then as the computers got faster our
climate models got better so one of the
things that has made our climate models
better is the size of the boxes has
gotten smaller so if you're trying to
simulate the atmosphere if you had were
giant boxes like if you subdivide the
the Earth's atmosphere into like 12
giant boxes that's not a very good
simulation they're smaller and smaller
you make the boxes the more realistic it
becomes but the more calculations are
required and the faster computer you
need to do this and so as our computers
have gotten faster our climate models
have gotten better so here's an example
of 1990s climate model so each Q was 270
by 270 kilometers well that's a pretty
big box and that's a that's the best
they could do of the computers at the
time but there could be a lot of things
going on inside that box
in the atmosphere that you would not be
able to simulate because your box is
simply too big so it when this slide was
made it says present day 135 by 135
today we have climate models that can do
30 kilometer by 30 kilometer boxes and
so today with today's fastest
supercomputers we can simulate the
atmosphere pretty well like we we are
box the boxes are small enough and the
math is tight enough that we do pretty
good simulations so once you have a
really good climate model that works you
can do different experiments with it and
this is there you have a diagram like
this in your book so let me try to
explain what this is a one of the IPCC
diagrams so let me try to explain what
they're doing here so imagine if you
went back to say the early 1900's and
you said ok we're going to change
history and humans are not going to add
any more greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere ok so what you would do in
your climate model is you would go
essentially back in time and say what
was the Earth's atmosphere look like
today modern time if we went back to the
early 1900's and we decided not to emit
greenhouse gases like what would have
happened and so the climate model cranks
away at the math and all those cubes and
it spits out an answer and then you can
go back and say ok what would the
climate be like today if we did put in
greenhouse gases and the computer cranks
it out and cranks out and spits out an
answer and we can compare those two
answers so this is kind of what they've
done here so let's look at this one here
that says global ok so there's a blue
envelope and the blue is kind of behind
the pink here from here to here and then
there's this pink and then there's this
black coin all right so they went back
to the early 1900's they asked the
supercomputer let's take out greenhouse
gasses that humans have added called
anthropogenic forcings that's what
they're calling it here
and let's just run this climate model
and see what it does and it spits out
now this is on the y-axis this is
temperature anomaly and here it says
zero so zero Degree temperature not only
means normal right
so what it says is that cranks out to
the year 2000 when this this one was
made and it says that worldwide
temperatures should have followed sort
of this blue envelope right here now the
reason is not a single line is that
there's multiple computer models that
are run by multiple research groups on
multiple computers and they all give a
slightly different answer but the
answers converge in this blue envelope
here okay or you could break it out by
continent like they did here in South
America or Africa or whatever okay so
then they run it again they say alright
can supercomputer let's throw in some
greenhouse gases and run it again and
see what you get so they do that again
and that's what this pink envelope is
here now you can see that the
temperatures would go up as we get close
to the year 2000 or if we look at South
America or if you look at Africa etc so
then so the so the supercomputer is
saying no green no anthropogenic
greenhouse gases the human the ones that
humans make no extra greenhouse gases
temperatures should have done what the
blue is showing with the greenhouse
gases temperatures would do what the
pink is showing the black is the
temperatures we actually measured so
these are real life temperatures that
people measured with thermometers over
time so what this is saying is that
temperatures that we actually measured
the black line correspond to the climate
model outputs that predicted this map
amount of warming with those extra
greenhouse gases so the other way to
think about is that if humans did not do
what we did if we didn't burn fossil
fuels we didn't add greenhouse gases to
the atmosphere the temperatures on earth
should be following the blue but instead
we follow we see that they're following
the pink now in a previous lecture we
went through some of the reasons why we
eliminated why sunspots are not the
source of global warming
why volcanoes are not the source of
global warming what
is this as sort of another piece of
evidence that says the math actually
checks out that the extra greenhouse
gases do provide the amount of extra
warming that we notice now for some
reason in in the in climate change world
the scientists use this term forcings
and you may have read that a bunch in
your book I don't like that term but
it's very popular so forcing means
you're going to add something to the
atmosphere that's going to force the
temperature to change okay that's what
it means so if I add more co2 to the
atmosphere that is a forcing it's going
to force the the warming to occur if I
have more sunspots that's another type
of forcing it's going to force the
climate to change so down here it says
models only using natural forcings what
that means is naturally occurring things
sunspots volcanoes naturally-occurring
greenhouse gases models using both
natural and anthropogenic forcings means
take all the folk a nose and sunspots
and all that and then also add the
greenhouse gases that humans are putting
in that's what they mean that's what
forcings mean it's I don't again it's a
word that I think it's kind of confusing
so recap here the blue line computer
model outputs without anthropogenic
greenhouse gases red computer model
outputs with anthropogenic greenhouse
gases black is the observed temperature
so what we can say is it's very likely
that the warming we're seeing is doing
is due to anthropogenic greenhouse gases
another way that we think about this is
we've kind of eliminated all other
possibilities right I mean we talked in
this class about sunspots and we talked
about volcanoes the Earth's orbit does
change but not nearly as fast as well to
explain the warming that we have so the
cut only thing we're really left with
are the greenhouse gases that we as
humans have added to the atmosphere and
the computer math basically says yeah
that looks like the most likely
explanation so the other thing that we
can do with climate models is we can use
them to try to predict the future so
once you have a really good simulation
of the atmosphere then you can ask it
questions like well how is that how is
the climate going to be different say a
hundred years from now
so we've got the math down and we have
the programming in the COS software down
but there's still one big uncertainty
and the big uncertainty is we don't know
what the future of greenhouse gas
emissions is going to be so there's a
part of your book early kind of part to
it mostly where it talks about how there
are these different scenarios that the
IPCC has put together and they have
these goofy names like RCP 8.5 and RCP
6.0 and so what they did is they got
together and they said look we don't
know what the future is gonna be like
but let's say what would happen if we
continue on the current path we are
right now right or burning a certain
amount of fossil fuels each year a
little bit more each year a little bit
more and let's just imagine that keeps
on going into the future or what would
happen if the countries got together and
they had some kind of treaty and they
said we're gonna cut greenhouse gas
emissions down right and so they come up
with another possible scenario like well
maybe one one of these and so the best
they can do is they come up with these
different scenarios and they put them
into the climate models and they
calculate what the result would be if we
went down these different paths but we
don't know what path we're going to go
down so that's what these emissions
pathways are all about so in your book
so here I am on page 92 and so here's a
graph that says global co2 emissions in
Giga tons of carbon per year and this is
time so the black is our historical
that's what we have humans have already
done how much co2 we put into the
atmosphere how much carbon and then here
it breaks into yellow at the time that
this graph was made it was a year 2000
and they were doing projections into the
future so you know depending on what you
know if the if the economy continues to
boom and there's no regulations well we
might go up
red curve and then if countries get
together and decided hey we should you
know save the earth well maybe that's
going to be the blue curve and so forth
so these are the different scenarios and
how the different projections played out
into the future
okay so then they asked the
supercomputers - okay well if if we did
say the orange curve
what would the temperature of the earth
be like by the time we get to the year
2100 right okay so a couple pages later
here's an example of what one of these
looks like so now the y-axis saw on page
98 global surface temperature change
alright so up to here this is - mm like
2005 which is the time that they made
this particular graph and RCP 8.5 that's
that was the red curve on the previous
one now it's this red with the pink
envelope around it saying okay if the
world follows the red path of that RCP
8.5 in the in the in the previous
diagram how will the temperature change
well it will change like this that's
what the computers are telling us and
the further out we go you can think of
it this is like the the red line is sort
of the center and this this is the range
of uncertainty around and the more the
further out you go in the future the
more uncertainty you get in your
prediction but what they're saying is if
we follow the red path the 8.5 path then
we will we will see temperatures
increase well in this pink zone which if
you look across here is somewhere
between 3 degrees and maybe 5 degrees
centigrade above where it should be
which in Fahrenheit is five and a half
degrees at night versus nine degrees and
nine degrees Fahrenheit above what it
should be
whereas if we picked the blue one right
this is the RCP 2.6 now what did what
was that that was the
okay that's kind of the best case
scenario this is the one where we all
get together as a world and we say we
gotta cut co2 emissions and we actually
make big measures probably like this
would be the best possible scenario like
if we all got together and we started
cutting our fossil fuel consumption a
lot well then that is this curve so it's
gonna it predicts that temperatures will
still going to increase a little bit
because we already have so much co2 in
the atmosphere already and they're going
to kind of stabilize along this purple
line so the computer models the climate
models are predicting that the climate
is going to change somewhere between you
can think of this is like best-case
scenario and maybe worst-case scenario
although it could be even a little bit
worse than this but realistically it's
probably going to be between these two
curves which means that by the year 2100
we're expecting temperatures to be about
one degree centigrade which is close to
two degrees Fahrenheit warmer than
normal up to maybe five degrees
centigrade or nine degrees Fahrenheit
warmer than normal so point being our
climate prediction models are only as
good as the as a prediction that we can
make to our greenhouse gas emissions so
what I've been doing in the in my
face-to-face classes is talk about some
of the history behind some of the
attempts that the world you know that
the world has seen that try to do
something about greenhouse gases so one
of the one of the things that comes out
of that modeling is that if we want
greenhouse gases to kind of be flat and
stop increasing we actually have to
start decreasing our greenhouse gas
emissions because there's so much
greenhouse gas emissions that are
already up into the atmosphere so one
day the big attempts was something
called the Kyoto Protocol and this was
adopted in 97 and then countries started
to follow it and you think of it like a
treaty when two countries getting
together signing a treaty to say we're
gonna start lowering our co2 emissions
and originally had
hundred ninety-two countries everybody
signing on thinking about how they're
gonna cut greenhouse gases but then in
2001 the u.s. drops out says well we're
not signing on to this and so we dropped
out of this particular treaty and then
more recently there was another attempt
called the climb espera de Paris climate
Accord and they were trying to limit the
future
temperature increases to about one and a
half degrees centigrade which again
means you gotta cut down those co2
emissions 195 countries signed on as of
2015 and as soon as Trump got in office
that was kind of one the first things he
did is he said we're out of the Paris
climate Accord and so now we've dropped
out so the problem with these treaties
is it's kind of a volunteer thing
countries get together they sign on but
no one's forcing you to stay so the u.s.
just left and in the problem with that
is historically the US has been the
number one contributor in greenhouse gas
emissions now today we're actually
number two China has taken the world as
the number one co2 emitter now if you
add up a whole bunch of other countries
together you get a big chunk too but the
three Biggie's are China US and the
European Union and enfold you know by a
bunch of other countries so you know
when we drop out we're like a major
major contributor to these to the
greenhouse gas emissions and then once
we drop out then the other countries are
saying well why are we gonna do this if
the u.s. is not going to do it if you
look at keywords have co2 emissions in
the past 150 years so this is not the
amount that we're emitting today this is
like all the co2 we've emitted since you
know late 1800s you see that the number
one by far is the United States and then
surprisingly number two is Germany and
the number three is China
okay so historically we've been the
biggest emitter and so when we drop out
of these treaties that kind of looks bad
for the United States
and then of course without going
political we have to talk about the
current political climate which is that
we currently have an administration that
thinks that global warming is not even
real so this is a famous tweet from
Donald Trump concept the global warming
was created by and for the Chinese in
order to make the US manufacturing
non-competitive so he's famously as has
said that he thinks everything I've been
telling you is is a hoax that the
Chinese government made up so with that
and with the fact that we have the head
of the EPA Scott Pruett also is a firm
non believer in climate changed that it
doesn't look like we're going to be
signing on any co2 treaties in the near
future
so the reason I'm bringing this up is
when we're trying to make these
predictions these types of curves right
now based on the current political
climate we're headed up this curve right
this is this is the one we're headed up
right now now let's say in a couple
years all the current administration is
thrown out of office and a new group
comes in and they say you know what
we're all about solar energy we're all
about wind power we're gonna we're going
to tax the fossil fuels whatever you
know whatever the scenario is maybe
that'll suddenly shift us and we'll be
on the blue path and maybe we'll be on
the blue path for four years and then
they get kicked out of office and then
another bunch of fossil fuel proponents
come in then we're shifting back to the
to the the black curve again so this is
why it's so hard to predict right over
the last few years we've been headed up
the black curve maybe it'll change maybe
it won't or what if there's a big
worldwide economic crash so we had one
in 2008 the amount of greenhouse gas has
started to go down because there was
less manufacturing because people were
buying less because we had less money
that could happen again right so so it's
really hard to predict the features so
this is why it's hard to predict the
climate change that's actually going to
occur in the next a hundred years or so
so let's look at a couple examples of
one of these climate model predictions
so the first one we're going to look at
is our CP 2.6 all right so from your
book this is the one where the country's
the whole world gets together realizes
the error of their ways and
significantly restricts greenhouse gas
emissions right I mean it's really not
realistic but let's just say that the
co2 emission curve looks like this it
goes down into the future and so the
year 2100 all right
what would the temperatures look like on
earth so this is the what we're gonna
look at here is the output of a model
where were we are looking at the globe
of the earth and we're gonna know this
one was run you know almost 10 years ago
2009 and it did a prediction is that if
the world follows this RCP 2.6 emissions
curve what do we get and the colors tell
us the temperature change in in this
case it's in Fahrenheit in the future
okay so we'll play this and so as years
go by here you can see that most of the
warming is occurring in the northern
hemisphere and over the continents which
is what we've seen before and I'm gonna
stop it when we get to the year 2100 ooh
so if I go back a little bit there so
most of the warming is occurring up near
the Arctic right and if you think back a
few lectures when we looked at the maps
of current warming the warming that
we've seen in the last hundred years we
see the most warming up here and what
this model is saying is that in the
future that's going to continue now
remember this is like an unrealistic
best-case scenario that that all you
know all the countries get together big
kumbaya we're gonna save the world we're
gonna cut co2 emissions and yet still we
see temperature increases up here kind
of
around seven to ten degree Fahrenheit
mark so that means seven to ten degrees
Fahrenheit above what it's supposed to
be okay so now let's compare that to
another one of the curves
okay so let's compare that so we just
saw the result the model output of this
future RCP 2.6 well let's go to the
other extreme let's look at the 8.5
which in a previous slide was the black
curve and in your book it's red but this
is the scenario that basically we're
currently on right we're headed up this
red curve if nothing else changes
alright so we're gonna play another one
of those movies and it's just like the
previous one except now we have
different emission scenario
so first the pattern looks pretty
similar we're seeing more warming over
the continents than the oceans more
warming over the northern hemisphere
than the rest but notice how much redder
these colors are right how much darker
they are so I'm gonna try to pause this
one and notice the reddest part up here
in the Arctic that's 25 degrees
Fahrenheit above normal and this is the
thing that you've got to keep in mind
when we do climate predictions climate
model predictions in the future it's
always given as a global so in other
words people say well the earth is going
to warm by two degrees or three degrees
you think what's two or three degrees
who cares but that's a global average
and remember that a lot of the earth
like out in the ocean along the equator
is not changing that much but in this
scenario they again the eight point five
scenario you've got areas up here in the
Arctic that have increased by twenty
five degrees Fahrenheit above average so
that's huge and we also see big
increases over land masses in the
northern hemisphere too right so up here
in northern Siberia
you know increases of
degrees Farenheit so these are crazy
numbers so the patterns that the climate
models are showing are the same kinds of
patterns that we've been seeing in the
previous maps of climate change today
more climate warming in the in the
northern hemisphere and more over the
continents and the oceans it's just kind
of a matter of degree right so this
scenario here the eight-point-five
scenario again that's business what they
call business as usual it's sort of the
path that we're on is the one that has
the the most warming the first one I
showed you which was the 2.6 that's like
best-case scenario and they're still
predicted to be some warming in the
northern hemisphere and over the oceans
so a major misconception that people
have about global warming on both sides
those that actually believe that it's
happening and those that deny that it's
happening or don't believe that it's
happening is as follows
so we talked about in the past lecture
about the roz be waivers right so here
what I'm looking at is I'm looking at
temperatures at the 700 million bar
level which is about 10,000 feet above
sea level and we talked about how
there's a very distinct boundary between
the warmest air and the much colder air
and that boundary is wavy those are the
rows B waves and they move right okay so
let's say I assume this is just from
today and if you remember back till we
talked about mid latitude cyclones and
fronts what we were saying is that these
two different air masses mix up together
so right now you've got a blob a pretty
cold air moving down south here and
you've got warm air that's moving up to
the north and here and up in here okay
so let's think about what two people two
different people might be experiencing
right now if you live here you you are
experiencing below normal temperatures
today because this cold air from the
north is coming down if you have here
you are experiencing warmer temperatures
than normal because this warm air is
moving up to the north right so we got
cold fronts and warm fronts we talked
about this in past lectures if you
didn't know anything about the weather
and you lived right here you might be
thinking oh where we are above normal
temperatures and if you live it over
here you're below normal temperatures
and if you wanted to you might try to
attribute that to global warming or not
so in other words the person that's
right here might be saying oh this
global warming it's so warm today right
but the reason it's warm today has
nothing to do with global warming it's
because they are in this warm air mass
that's moving to the north and these
people here might be thinking ah
global warming is a hoax because think
look how cold it is today but it has
nothing to do with global warming or not
it's just that they are in this pool of
cold air sinking down from the from the
north this is what happens over and over
in the discussion about global warming
every day around the world there are
places that are below average
temperature and there are places that
are above average temperature it's all
happens all the time and if we look
around the you know if I look just
what's happening today here's a place
where this cold air coming down
warm air going up so again if you lived
over here you are below average
temperatures if you lived here you're
above average right if I go over here
here's another one this is a blob of
cold air they're below average this
right here is above average over here
these guys are above average
these guys are below average so normally
when you go around the world you see a
bunch of zones that are above average
and you see a bunch of zones that are
below average and they even out like
mathematically all of this should kind
of equal itself out and you should have
an earth that's just average with global
warming what we're talking about is that
average is very slowly creeping up and
up but I bring this up because it comes
up in the news a lot where people will
say oh it's so hot today it's that
global warming no that's not vogel
warming means it's not a day-to-day
thing that you can recognize it's a
long-term trend or politicians will say
oh it's cold and it's snowing out here
and it's May global warming must be a
hoax
no you're mixing up two different air
masses has nothing to do with global
warming so people that are both believe
in it and that people that don't believe
in it still use this erroneously as an
argument on either side so one way to
think about global warming is to think
about a bell curve most places where you
live on earth especially once you get
away from the equator and you're up in
higher latitudes is that for any
particular place we have a number of
days you
we've got a few hot super hot days we've
got a few super cold days and everything
else kind of fits into a bell curve and
the bell curve might be extra fat it
might be extra narrow just depends on
the climate of where you live but the
point is most of our days kind of fall
in here with a few extremes over here
and a few extremes over here so I'm
gonna draw a little line here to
represent hot outliers and cold outliers
right so so this zone right here you
might consider this like your heat waves
right these are your you're really hot
events where you know some people die
from exposure to heat makes the news etc
okay so you expect that there's there's
gonna be a few maybe record-breaking
cold events a few record-breaking hot
events but most days are kind of in the
middle now let's say I shift the climate
just a couple of degrees right it's the
earth gets warmer three degrees what's
the big deal three degrees it might be
warmer three degrees tomorrow might be
colder three degrees tomorrow nobody
knows the difference who cares what that
really means first of all it's a global
average so as we saw in the previous
section parts of the earth are going to
get much much much warmer than that that
three degrees whereas a lot of it may be
around the equator doesn't change at all
but let's just say for this particular
location I increase the temperature
three degrees what that means is that
this whole curve is being shifted over
three degrees okay so I'm going to
redraw this but as a dotted line now or
it's been shifted over
okay so this right here that's our three
degree increase okay so we've shifted
the average over three degrees what does
that do to these extremes though these
tails notice what happens to our tail of
cold events on this new dashed line we
basically don't have them anymore
we're losing those cold events the
record-breaking cold events when you did
your climate change assignment where you
you went and you look one of the things
that we saw when we go back like a
hundred years is that starting like in
the 90s we start losing those colder
winters right well this is this is why
now the other thing that happens is how
many of these hot events do we now have
so if I shifted this curve over I now
have a much broader area of these hot
events so by just shifting this over a
little bit I increase the area under the
curve for this tail and I decrease the
area under the curve for this tail so as
humans what this means is we get a lot
more of these dangerous hot events a lot
more of these heat waves so this is why
it's a little deceptive when people say
temperature's increases three degrees
Fahrenheit natural reaction is big deal
but it's the whole average that's
shifting three degrees and it's this
tail that we worry about because now
we've got more of these hot de Vence
than we used to have so we can already
see the consequence of these additional
heat events around the world and one
thing to keep in mind when we talk about
climate change is that the people who
are the most affected are not us here in
the United States and we have this we're
kind of spoiled with our infrastructure
right if so if it's extra hot we just
turn on our air conditioners on but a
lot of the world can't do that and it's
kind of astonishing how many people die
from these extreme heat events so these
slides I'm going to show you or just
some stories from 2015 I could update
them and give you some more stories for
this year but these are the slides that
I had and so for example in 2015
you know heatwave in India kills over
2,000 people right like that's nuts we
would never see something like that here
in the US Pakistan heatwave that same
year kills 1200 people you know that we
didn't get into heat index in this
country or in this class but if you have
high relative humidities and you add to
that high temperatures you can produce
you know it feels like it's hotter than
it really is and we call that heat index
so that year Iran hit 163 degrees heat
index so what that means it is it felt
like there's a hundred sixty-three
degrees outside so that was a
combination of the high temperatures and
high humidity that they had heat wave
hit Europe people died again but not in
the numbers that we saw in some of those
other countries hits Japan when this
story was run that 55 people died
eventually that would become 90 so heat
waves are you know have real-world
consequences and thousands of people
actually died from these each year also
another consequence of climate change is
that you're getting flooding in places
that aren't used to it you're also to be
fair getting droughts in place that
aren't places that aren't used to it as
we kind of briefly talked about in the
past we're shifting weather patterns
around a little bit as we change the
climate and so there's human
consequences for these flooding events
where you know millions of people are
having to leave their homes and there
are death tolls and in the hundreds
often or these places flood and again
we're not really used to this I mean how
far back do you have to go to find you
know a hundred people in the United
States died from the flood doesn't
happen very often but in other parts of
the world you're not nearly as lucky all
so getting flooding in places that you'd
never expect much rain at all so again
this is the all these stories worth from
2015 and in Egypt Alexandria so the
caption says Alexandria would usually
only expect to see five millimeters of
rain during the entire month right and
this one event they got you know what
equivalent of several inches of rain
that flooded this area so many
centimeters of rain now we saw this
image once before which is a record of
number of hours of flooding per year in
a neighborhood near the coast and we
talked about how this is partly due to
rising sea levels you know there are
several places in the world where the
land is pretty close to sea level and
Bangladesh is one of them and we
expected 17% of the landmass of
Bangladesh will be underwater in the
next 40 years and that's going to
displace 18 million people all right so
this is a country that's you know it's
built on a delta it's very flat very
near sea level so the sea goes up just a
little bit - floods a very broad area 40
I mean 18 million people that's a lot of
people are gonna have to go somewhere
this woman is standing where her house
used to be before it got washed away
another consequence of climate change
and by the way we're just going through
you know these are things that are in
your book that your book talks about and
in like the first half of your book or
whatever more wildfire so the warmer you
make the earth the lower the relative
humidity the lower the relative humidity
the more chance of fires and so again
this is I went through is these slides
this one in particular year 2015 and
just got all the stories about the
record-breaking wildfires and I could do
this the year after the year after the
year after and you still get the same
stories so this on this particular year
we had record-breaking wildfires burning
eight million acres northwest wildfire
fires northwestern us that is break
records for size and cost
The Australian's battle the worst bush
fires for last 30 years and so again
pretty much every year it's the same
cycle and news stories that are coming
out here's kind of a strange graph is
this is from Australia and it says
number of days
hotter than 99% of all days ever
recorded right so if we go back to the
40's right so like this year right here
on what that is 1936 they had five days
that year that were hotter than 99% of
all days ever recorded and then compared
and again remember long-term changes is
what we're looking for in for climate
change there's you know years that are
clearly hotter and years that are
clearly colder but the overall trend is
that they're seeing more and more of
these years where they have more and
more record-breaking hot days right so
this last one on this graph you know
they looks like they've got about 27
days that were hotter than 99% of all
days ever recorded so sometimes people
use this term extreme weather I don't
like that term because who knows exactly
what you consider extreme but I know
this gets in the news a lot and I think
your book refers to it so I throw this
in here the number of extreme weather
events has been going up and up this is
again usually attributed to climate
change but it's a little fuzzy as to
exactly what's going on here and what
counts as extreme weather so I don't
really like to get into that too much
but I thought I would throw that in
there so a more important idea is the
threats to agriculture and the world's
food supply and one of the things we've
got to realize here is that here in the
United States we've got this factory
farming system we're making more food
than we can use and we export a lot of
it but a lot of the world does not have
that and in fact the the farmers that
are going to experience you know the
worst consequences from climate change
are the little farmers so here
stars as small farmers in Africa will
experience the worst of climate change
small holders with less than five acres
produce much of the world Lord's food
and and so when you have a shifting you
know shifting precipitation patterns or
it's now it's getting warm more of these
warm events you're gonna see a lot of
crop failure ah on a small scale so in
other words here in the United States if
we go into a drought well we could drill
a well we could pump water right I mean
there's things that we can do but a lot
of the world can't do that they don't
have the infrastructure to do that so so
we're gonna see a lot of crop failure
and the places that can't afford it the
most and it's worth pointing out that
the world is not necessarily getting as
much to eat as they would like and this
is again something that we don't think
about a lot in our country this is a map
of hunger so white means you got plenty
to eat no problem
the dark green means that maybe there's
a few you know maybe five percent or so
or less of the population that's not
getting enough to eat and then as you
start to get into these other colors you
start to get I come into the red where
over 20 percent of the population is
basically starving and you so you see a
lot of hunger say in central Africa well
we just said that that's the part of the
world that's going to be the meal the
most danger most at risk for crop
failure as climate change starts to set
in so you're taking us an area of the
world that's already hurting for a food
supply and you're gonna make it worse
once you start changing precipitation
patterns and adding these additional
heat events number 6 on our list would
be threats to livelihood and so we saw
in those previous climate animate
climate change animations that the
predictions that the northern you know
up in the Arctic that that part is going
to be affected the most most of all by
future climate change has already
received the most change up till now and
it's going to contain
that way in the future so there's a lot
of coaches like the Inuit that their
livelihood depends on the present say of
ice and they're gonna have to do
something different because that ice is
no longer gonna be there and we saw in
that one prediction that it was going to
you know this area was gonna increase by
25 degrees Fahrenheit by the year 2100
so something's gonna have to really
change here in the in their livelihood
in the okay last on our list of
consequences of climate change are
threats to ecosystems and this diagram
was in your book and it's kind of
confusing I want to go over this a
little bit so the idea is that groups of
organisms can migrate and part of this
is common sense that if you're a big
animal and you need to move you just get
up and go but other groups of organisms
can also migrate at a much lower rate so
for example trees can migrate now how
would they do that
well tree grows up propagate seeds the
seeds then start a new tree which then
propagates seeds which in start a new
tree in that forest as a whole could
move in one direction or the other if it
had to and so if you look at a range on
this graph of all trees the slowest
trees could propagate so on the waxes
that says maximum speed at which species
can move in kilometers per decade right
so this is 20 so right in the middle of
be about 10 so this bar represents all
trees in the world and the speediest
trees looks like they could propagate it
maybe 15 kilometers per decade slows
trees maybe I don't know half a
kilometer per decade something like that
the black bar is what is the median so
you can think like that's where most
trees are so it looks like most trees
might be able to propagate about a
kilometer per decade right so if you got
a compa trees and they've got to stay in
a certain temperature range to survive
and then the climate is going to change
could the trees move fast enough to get
to a cooler area
to survive or any of these other
organisms right so if you think of like
a squirrel so a squirrel could get up
and and go except it has to stay within
its habitat in order to survive right so
let's say you got a compa trees and
surrounding the clump of trees is I
don't know a prairie and for whatever
reason the squirrels have to live in the
trees well the squirrels cannot migrate
any faster than the trees so the trees
are slowly propagating in one direction
then the squirrels are propagating at
the same speed as the trees right they
can't go any faster than the trees or
they will run out of habitat so let's
imagine I have two clumps of trees here
I've got one clump that's on a pretty
flat you know pretty flat ground I get
another clump that's near some pretty
steep terrain so if I change the
temperature I make things warmer so if
these trees are going to survive they
need to get to a higher elevation okay
so these guys don't have to maybe they
only have to go up just a little bit
maybe to here to get to the cooler
temperature and then there would be fine
right so maybe this this batch only has
to migrate up to here let's say and
they'll be in cooler temperatures and
they'll be fine
this group has to go up you know to get
this change in elevation let's say it's
a centimeter on my map maybe that means
that this group has got to get to about
here to be the same distance you know
that same increase in elevation to get
to here so that they can survive but of
course this is a very long area for them
to migrate so the point is is if you
have a group of organisms or forest
that's on flat land they're going to
have to travel a much longer distance to
get to a cooler temperature then if you
had a group of organisms that would say
on the side of the hill these guys don't
have to go very far to get to higher to
to get to higher elevation for the
cooler temperatures this groups got to
go much farther to get to an equivalent
elevation gain okay so with that idea
let's go back to this graph so we're
going back to these our CP predictions
right the scenarios the emission
scenarios so if I had a our CP 2.6
remember that's the best possible
scenario that's this in your book it's
the purple one on here what it says is
if we had our CP 2.6 it says fought
areas in global average this is the rate
at which the earth is going to warm and
what we see is pretty much most of the
organisms on this graph can migrate
faster than that so that's good news the
earth is going to warm a little bit but
most most organisms including those on
flat areas will be able to go faster
than the warming and will survive but
let's say we have our CP 6.0 so back on
here our CP 6.0 that is the orange one
okay and so this is not as Extreme as
the sort of business as usual scenario
8.5 it's somewhere in between so let's
just say that this is the future our CP
6.0 that's the emission scenario that
happens and the earth warms up
accordingly and so what this is saying
it says our CP 6.0 global average this
is the rate at which the earth will warm
and organisms that are below this line
will not be able to move fast enough to
escape the warming organisms that are
above this line will be able to go fast
enough to get to to cooler areas so of
all the trees in the world the trees
that fall up in this zone will be able
to accelerate fast enough to go beat you
know to get to higher elevations to
cooler temperatures the the trees that
are below us all the species below here
won't be able to do that and will
we go extinct up here says RCP 6.0 flat
areas so any organisms that are stuck
out in the in the flat areas there
they're in trouble because they're not
going to be able to accelerate the the
warming fast enough so all these guys
would go extinct in that scenario if
they were stuck out in the flattens in
the flat areas these types of organisms
would be okay because they could
conceivably move faster than this amount
of warming or if you go to the 8.5
remember the 8.5 that's the worst case
scenario that's the business-as-usual
that's the one we're probably on right
now so we move from this line to this
line so again any organisms that fall
below this red line means that they were
not going to move fast enough to outpace
the warming and then here's the flat
area so any organisms that's out on the
flat area below this line will not
survive so that's I think is kind of a
confusing diagram to explain this but
all you got to know here is that
different groups of organisms can
migrate at different speeds sometimes
it's just the speed of the organism
itself it can just pick up and walk off
sometimes it's the speed of the habitat
in which the organism lives
so again if you're a squirrel and you
live in the trees you can oil migrate as
fast as the trees at the forest itself
is migrating and in these different
emission scenarios the earth is going to
warm at different rates and so the
question is as a group of organisms can
you outpace the warming and to get to a
cooler area in time if you live near a
hill high elevation it doesn't take as
long to get to up to a cooler spot if
you live where it's flat you got a long
long ways to go to finally get to say a
higher latitude or something you have a
much much lower chance of surviving
there's one graph on your book on page
50 that is pretty important but I don't
think they quite point out how important
it is so what it's showing is that's
showing global average temperatures back
to 20,000 BC and you see that they rise
up we're coming out
an ice age and then and by the way the
ice age was due to changes in the
Earth's orbit right but that happens
very slowly and then there's this thing
it says the Holocene maximum and you see
it kind of dive down a little bit and
all of a sudden it takes off and this is
you know the trajectory that we're on
okay so the point of this is that the
amount of warming that we're seeing
right now is very rapid compared to what
we've seen in the past but I want to
talk about this part of the graph and in
in I'm going to show you a different
version of this and this is the graph
that I generally show my class and
there's some confusing things here so
let's just simplify on the y-axis think
of this is temperature okay something
called Delta o-18
in it's something that's chemically
removed from shells to reconstruct
temperatures does not worry about that
point is if you go back these are this
is a hundred thousand years ago right 80
thousand years ago we see some pretty
crazy changes in the Earth's climate
right we've got warm periods we got cold
periods we got back to warm periods so
what you might say is that we're kind of
in these you know ice ages or in between
ice ages and there's a lot of craziness
right a lot of wild swings in the
Earth's or in the Earth's climate and we
don't necessarily all agree on what's
causing these big swings in the Earth's
climate some of its orbit some of it may
not be but here's the strange thing
about 10,000 years ago the climate
suddenly gets really calm and it gets
and it turns flat okay and we are living
at the end of this flat zone now as
humans we need agriculture to survive
and it turns out that the beginning of
Agriculture was about 10,000 years ago
and there's a hypothesis that humans
could not develop
culture until the climate kind of
settled down so we went so the earth
ghost is pretty crazy period and then
for whatever reason tends to calm down
and again climate scientists are not a
hundred percent certain why why this
actually happened why did we go creek
from crazy town to this kind of nice
calm period but here's the fear the fear
is as we talked about in the previous
lecture about greenhouse gases that
we've suddenly just injected a ton of
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
that aren't supposed to be there and
we've put more greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere now than the earth has seen
in the last million years so the analogy
is often that we're poking a sleeping
bear right the atmosphere was going
along just fine climate was nice and
kind of flat no crazy stuff and then the
humans come along and they start adding
all this co2 and other greenhouse gases
and one of the big big questions that we
have is climate scientists and the
public doesn't really ever this has
really never discussed is we don't know
what's keeping the climate that constant
over the past 10,000 years and we
especially don't know how it's going to
react to all of this extra greenhouse
gases when we poke the bear what is
going to happen and it's quite possible
that the climate system could return to
crazytown over here again and we just
don't know in our climate models that
we've we've been talking about we you
know and all the tools that we have as
climate scientists there's still a level
uncertainty of what is actually going to
happen in the future it's pretty easy to
predict that things will get warmer what
we don't know is whether things will
come crashing down soon after like it
did in the past so the biggest fear
about climate change and again this is
not really something that most people
you know that the public doesn't know
about this too much that's not really in
the news it's not even that much in your
book is that we don't know how
along this calm period this last 10,000
year long calm period we don't know how
long this is gonna last and we don't
know what its gonna happen after that
but we're pretty sure that if we keep
adding greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere that something is probably
going to change we just don't know how
it's going to change so I've talked from
time to time about how climate change is
very politicized and I thought I'd in
this class talking a little bit more
about that because you may not realize
quite what's what's been going on so I I
work with a lot of teachers in New
Mexico like K through 12 teachers and in
K through 12 they're supposed to teach
weather and climate that's part of the
new science standards and I work with
some teachers to try to help them
understand weather and climate better so
that they can teach it so this is a book
that many of my teachers have received
in the mail and it says why scientists
disagree about global warming so the
title by itself is a huge lie because
I'm a client climate scientist I've gone
to many climate scientist meetings where
there might be thousands of scientists
present nobody's disagreeing that global
warming is happening what we disagree
about are they are the minut details
especially like projections into the
future so by the year 2100 how much is
it how much is the temperature going to
change that's where the disagreement
lies or maybe when we look at paleo
climate and we see shifts in the climate
like a hundred thousand years ago you
know we disagree about the reasons for
that no one's disagreeing about what's
happening today okay so the title is an
outright lie
and you'll also see that this second
sentence is there's a little trickery
afoot here it says the nipcc report on
scientific consensus remember the IPCC
we learned who they were so this is the
n IPCC the not the IPCC but this book
was printed up by a conservative group
and distributed to they printed up over
a hundred thousand of them and they
tried to mail into every teach
in the country and the whole point is to
generate misinformation about climate
change and to tried to produce doubt in
the teachers that are actually supposed
to be teaching the students about
weather and climate so this is an
example of some of the misinformation
that's going on there's a lot of money
in the fossil fuel industry that are
trying to fight the the scientists that
are trying to get the message out about
climate change this is one example so a
lot of the things that are going on for
example they hired a lot of the same
people that were represented tobacco
companies in the 1980s so in the 1980s
is kind of when people finally realized
that smoking was really bad for you and
they had all these scientists from the
tobacco companies that were saying no no
smoking's fine for you fine for you and
there was a lot of misinformation that
was generated to try to convince people
that maybe smoking really wasn't bad for
you a lot of those same people are
actually now being hired to do this kind
of work trying to refute climate change
research you know all of the lectures
that you've watched here have been
posted on YouTube and usually I post one
up and you guys watch it and maybe a few
other people watch it and maybe there's
a comment or two or usually there's no
comments at all because I mean who cares
right it's some guy in this cat talking
about humidity nobody cares but as soon
as I put the word climate change in the
lecture title everything changed
and so a couple of lectures ago we had I
had a lecture up about that just kind of
reviewing stuff out of your book and had
the word climate change in the title and
all of a sudden this army of trolls just
came out of the woodwork and started
making comments on my my lecture and all
of my other videos and started sending
harassing emails messages to me and
finally I had to actually hide a lot of
our videos from in this class so that
they couldn't comment on them and then
also lay down with me
and then also prevent them from leaving
comments and just everything changed
like as soon as I used as soon as I put
in the words climate change or global
warming then all these people came out
that this whole army trolls came out to
to attack me and attack this class so
that's that's the world we're currently
living in and maybe in a different
administration that might change I
suspect that it probably won't change
for a long time but realize that this is
a this is a topic that's highly
politically charged and there's a lot of
money to try to convince you that global
warming isn't real and that burning
fossil fuels is not a problem
Romy's getting irritated so I guess
we're done with this class and thank you
for for listening and watching all these
videos and I hope you got something out
of it and I think we're done Rumi I
think we're done
you